we're joined now by the conservative mp
for rutland and melton alicia kearns
thank you so much for being with us
we were just talking to grant shapster
about uh refugees he's hoping to get
some ukrainian family of ukrainian
family into his home and i know that
you've been
involved in pairing ukrainian families
to people in your constituency and also
fellow mps
how have you found honestly how have you
found the system to navigate
so
the frustration is that you have to know
ukrainians to be able to match with them
uh the good news is because i have the
privilege of working with the most
amazing group of ukrainian mps they've
matched me with i think i think so far
i've matched 26 uh ukrainian families to
i think 20 homes in my constituency and
then another five or six families to uh
british mps who are willing to take
people into their homes and it has been
a mixed picture i have one visa that was
applied for on the monday and came
through by the tuesday afternoon um i've
got another visa that has been in the
system now for 10 days um
the frustration is obviously we still
need to go faster and further in terms
of making sure people can apply in their
own language and that we get these
things done quickly but when i speak to
ukrainian mps actually they're saying we
want you to do security checks because
we want this to work and there is a
difference to other schemes and that we
are inviting people into british
people's homes so there is a there is a
duty of care there to make sure this is
going to work um but so far we've got a
number of people arriving tomorrow um
and i think we're all very much looking
forward to working them into our homes
i do
totally recognize the duty of care when
people are coming into individuals homes
from both sides from the uk side but
also from the ukrainian family side as
well
but should the visa process be at least
changed in some way to allow people to
get out of ukraine as quickly as they
can and then some of the bureaucracy can
be done when they're here in the united
kingdom
we all want this to move as quickly as
possible and i think the scenes we're
seeing from bucca and from mario paul
make clear that there are war crimes
taking place and we want people out as
soon as possible the vast majority of
ukrainians that i've been matching with
my constituents are actually already out
of ukraine so they are applying from
hungary or from germany or from poland
and places like that so
do you
know that ukrainians are getting out
safely and now we just need to get them
to the uk
okay a couple of issues with the signal
there but i think it should be okay now
so we're going to keep going and we were
talking about the energy strategy as
well and this of course links into the
cost of living a crisis has been stories
in the newspapers today about up to
seven new nuclear stations and it was
interesting listening to grant shapso he
was pretty firm on the idea of onshore
wind saying it was an eyesore that's not
something that he could support and do
you think that the government is right
to be moving away from onshore wind
so i think the offshore wind is the
greatest opportunity that we have in
terms of energy and i know that the
prime minister's spoken before about
being the saudi arabia of wind you know
we have the celtic sea i think that's
where we should be investing the
majority of our wind focus uh in terms
of onshore wind i'm probably one of the
only people in the country that thinks
that uh onshore wind is actually quite
beautiful in its own way uh but i
recognize that i don't probably
represent the majority there so i think
offshore wind should absolutely be our
priority and that also allows us to move
away from our reliance on these
dangerous solar farm supply chains where
too many of the companies are bound up
in the genocide we're seeing of the
uyghur
at the same time though it's probably
right to declare your own interest i
mean you've campaigned to stop a solar
farm in your constituency
is this not part of the issue though
that you know
if we are going to get energy security
and an energy supply that is going to
heat people's homes and securely
someone's going to have to live near
solar farms onshore wind farms nuclear
power stations as well i mean how are
you going to square that
we already have solar plants in rutland
the mountain and we will have more solar
plants in rotten debt in the future but
what i won't accept is having a company
such as canadian solar who have been
they've had some of their suppliers
sanctioned by the us government they've
had four shipments of their solar plants
to the us taken off them because they
have been proven now including by report
by the university of sheffield to be
complicit in the genocide of the weaker
people i will not have uh bloodstained
solar panels essentially pollute our
environment there are alternatives to
polysilicon that can go into solar
panels there's a great piece of work
done at loughborough university there
are companies that are producing these
solar panels now without polysilicon so
we can clean up our supply chains we can
stop using the cheap uyghur slave labor
that is making the vast majority of
solar panels around the country in the
world at the moment but that's a choice
in the decision we have to make so i'm
not saying no to solar quite the
opposite i'm saying we want cleaner
solar and solar that isn't cheap for us
because it's built on the blood and
slave labor of others
now i want to talk to you a bit about
maternity care in the united kingdom you
know
and just sort of speaking frankly for a
minute you know on a sunday show you're
often looking to throw forward to
stories that are happening next week
like the energy security strategy
and but i actually want to just take a
moment and speak about a story that i
found extremely passionately affecting
this week
and it is this
story that 201 babies and nine mothers
died as a result of failings at the
shuri's b and telford nhs trust i mean
we're talking about the deaths of more
than 200
babies and i know that you're someone
who's spoken out about maternity care
before
can we really say the uk is a safe place
for women to give birth in
i think
i think that reports
the anger and the heartbreak that i have
felt and clearly you have felt and so
many ass has felt
i have to say that as an mp over the
last two and a half years i have sadly
had to conclude that nhs bureaucracies
are inherently and systematically sexist
there is a constant expectation that
women's services and care can be done on
the cheap or that because women have
given birth for generations and
generations they don't deserve the
support they need and my mother saw me
speak out in parliament and actually she
said to me that she remembered when she
was giving birth to my brother and she
asked for a c-section no i like she
asked for an epidural and because she'd
been in labor for so many days and so
many in so much pain
and she remembers being screamed at by
the consultant and told you think you're
special you're not special women do this
every day
again i shared my own experience of
having a c-section i ended up being
taken to the operating theatre twice
um because they weren't willing to give
me the c-section that i needed when i'd
been in labor 36 hours and my son had
already almost died once because of this
obsession with stats and low c-section
rates and also this idea that there was
a normal birth there is no such thing as
the births that we see in movies some
women have amazing birth stories that
these should not be expected of all
women um and i do worry that we have
seen it be very unsafe over the last two
years as we saw the campaign that you
and i spoke about a lot about partners
being locked up the room that made women
less safe so i think we have a way to go
but i think anyone who's watching this
is about to go into labor
know that our hospitals are safe but you
need to know that you have every right
to challenge the system and to say at
any point wait know why what are the
alternatives and why are you doing this
it is your body and you have a right to
challenge and demand better and demand
what you need to keep you safe
i think this is exactly it isn't it it's
this feeling that
what happened at sheridan's health is
the the worst example of when the system
goes wrong but every woman and many
women listening to this program
all their mothers or their sisters or
their friends will have their own
stories of birth not going in the way
that they wanted of losing control of
the birth and of not feeling safe or
supported and i think it as you say it
goes back to that thing about women
being listened to
what needs to change going forward and
what can the government do to try and
make the situation better or less sexist
as you say
i think sajid is exactly the man to deal
with this he cares deeply
about fighting for women's rights he
cares deeply about families and
supporting them and i know that he has
been personally found it very hard
seeing the conclusions of this report
and how much women and families i mean
people lives were lost and that
heartache and pain that people went
through is something that they will
still be living with today
and so i have absolute confidence that
sergeant is going to make sure maternity
system gets what it needs he's given it
the biggest investment of funds that i
think it's ever seen
and i believe truly that if there is a
health secretary that will fight for it
it is sadjid and he will make sure that
women's voices are listened to and he
has committed to looking around the
country to make sure that we don't see
something like this again
okay thank you for talking so openly
about um
about what happened and your own
experiences as well and just finally
you've been um on the uh gay conversion
therapy ban i was just keen to try and
unpick what exactly happened
this week first the prime minister said
it was gonna be banned then he
backtracked then he was contacted by 60
mps i believe including yourself um and
then he said it would be bad can you
just unpick what exactly went on because
it looks pretty shambolic from someone
on the outside
um look obviously i don't work in number
10 i don't know exactly what happened
but i do know that when i got elected i
went to the prime minister and said we
need to ban conversion therapy it is
wrong it tells every gay and trans
person in this country that they don't
deserve to be loved that they have some
sort of pathology that can be cured and
that is wrong and he was he was really
surprised that it was still legal
because when he was mayor of london he
banned the advertising conversion
therapy on the tube because he
recognized how wrong and dangerous it
was so in all my conversations with him
he has backed this ban entirely it was
in the last queen speech um and then yes
on friday we saw this leaked document
that suggests the government was going
to drop the ban um and i think
colleagues very rightfully made clear to
the prime minister and to everyone else
within the system how strongly they felt
that this cannot continue within our
country we will not allow gay and trans
people to feel attacked threatened and
unsafe in our country by allowing this
legislation to well essentially this
appalling quackery and fraudulent
activity to continue in our country
and the good thing now is that the
promise has been cleared the ban will go
forward um but for me now it's about
making sure it is the right ban and that
crucially we don't say that trans people
will be excluded from this ban because
they are vulnerable
and when people want to criticize this
bill i would say very clearly if you are
arguing that there's not enough critical
conversations taken with young people
who are questioning their gender
identity then you should back this bill
because this bill says if you are
questioning your sexuality or your
gender identity
then when you want to have these
challenging critical and safe
conversations they should take place
with a regulated and accredited
individual not a quack not a woke hippie
around the corner someone who will
genuinely work with you and support you
through this process that should be what
we want for all of our children and we
should want to send a very clear message
that everyone in this country deserves
to be loved and that being who you are
is never a pathology
okay thank you for being on the program
today we are out of time thank you